welcome to this video playing Barry ton
okay 1980 this is really a big gap in
reading okay oh and let him a couple of
times five out of six so he got a couple
of a couple of drawers in two drawers
okay I'm going for this hippopotamus set
up I don't really think it's a bad set
up against this type of this type of
formation for widen well its aggressive
cheerful
I mean whatever you can say about it
it's not the kind of set up that black
usually uses quickly with you he's not
getting blown out of the water quickly
this is just not happening f ing for
that's well that's a puzzling puzzling a
sequence of moves there what is he doing
d5 and 494 Wow and isn't this good for
me I mean night only for looks nice and
well if he has to take it that looks
looks weird okay so we just moved the
Queen I wonder if I should go age 5 in
this position for night f5 maybe not
sure about it if he goes g5 at all I
mean here's alternatives though
so the H file is opened so let's let's
do this try to break open the center
very a very weird complicated position
okay what is this I can take 1c three or
d 2 if I tikati too yeah okay that's
that's I think it's good I can check on
g4 and play knight c6 and which it takes
a five and attacks deform an additional
idea is Bishop f8 with a temper on the
rook which is quite important yeah let's
take and put a weight and let's let's
not be too quick here can I just win e5
that would be really nice if I can do
this quince is several
no okay the bishop coming to see five is
good let's do that well I didn't see
that one are you five I got the should
be five hmm Wow let's a move I should
have seen
okay and just prevent a form and just go
from here queen here I still have Bishop
g7 I mean okay it seems that this Bishop
f8 idea was unsuccessful but I still
have this idea against you five so so
Bishop back and now I could look aged 4
or something look aged 3 is actually
quite nice ideas rook f 32 f form I have
to be careful the rook is unprotected
night be five is a move Wow William
night be five if he sees that I'm in
trouble oh it's not such a big problem
wah wah wah wah I can play Queen
somewhere Queen the aid or something 96
I can take the night because of the uh
no k is not doing it but he's getting
this idea n Bishop b5 check so let's
move my king away okay so my idea still
is rook f3 to f4 okay I'm overlooking
many things in this game so course not I
wanted to do this ok so I have to trade
their ultimately yeah it's still okay
this this kind of disposition but
somehow it feels like I've dodged
bullets him he had some options
okay let's put this pressure on you five
okay
so maybe a five here to open up the door
inside a little bit Quincy High for the
end game is this an idea I don't really
know hi ship is not great down be
someone but you always has to take care
about the e5 pawn okay
time warning
Bishop is really a problem and don't
like to to let them trade there but okay
I'm down on time oh I have to this is
the sound taking it was the whole point
of my game to have this pressure ok 44
and down on time quite a bit check
uh 94 check that was quite problematic
okay didn't do it okay that should be
reasonably easy with the time check
check check yeah just push push push now
42 record of 32 immediately check check
check
white roses on it was a very shaky game
somehow yeah this is a bit weird for
wide because it's not quite clear what
his King is doing you just decided to
keep it in the middle this looked really
nice but I couldn't really could really
refute it oh oh that was very easy I
just have to check oh I did not see that
one I just have c4 there I can just win
the win apiece ya know okay and 96 is
much stronger again than taking yeah
until okay Queen c7 was better does this
idea I didn't really I didn't really am
and see how how a tougher defenses tool
is ok black is better but it's not it's
not so easy compass on minus one Bishop
a I have the weaknesses to play this is
interesting but I can teach you out so
yeah that that's in fact the refutation
ok so here king out of it yeah the point
is that those weaknesses here especially
e5 and e5 before and he's playing
against the bishop that's not going away
maybe a five was great I don't know yeah
here here you should just take which is
probably equal with the opposite colored
bishops but I didn't see a way to
otherwise what to do with my bishop and
instead he he blundered this porn after
which the endgame is a pretty pretty
simple win yeah ok thanks for watching